also erst jetzt und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute mitbekommen
letzter zeit gab es negative hat wieder
mal um die paul brüder und jetzt
wahrscheinlich das letzte video von
logan paul gesehen wurde so müssen sich
ganz schuldig zurück
deswegen würde ich sagen ist die phase
der videos verlogen paletten zwei aber
die phase der video jackpot
ich habe mich letztens beim durchstöbern
von youtube ein video gesehen und das
heißt dass wir nach diesem video wirst
du jack poole hassen wir schauen uns
heute an und wir gucken habe danach
checken lassen wie bisher was ich mal
kurz was da ist dass das barometer ok
erkennt man dass das barometer ist oder
und ich trage immer einfach da bin ich
gerade bin ich bin jetzt gerade
ich bin hier erstmal dazu es war ein
song von reis kam es auch in anderen
amerikanische youtuber in dem ein
jackpot ist hat mit jackpot ex freundin
zusammen
susanne arbeitet die normale zeit ist
okay das ist schon lieber sozial also
für alle die das noch nicht ganz
verstanden haben was er gemacht hat er
ist wie gesagt also der pollanten sorgen
macht ist er wieder der war also ich
würd ich hätte aber dann mal dieses
zimmer so das level an musik qualität
ist und da hinten es null und 100
nachdem die saison dann draußen war hat
reis kam dann ist derweil jack falls ex
freundin die auch mit jack folge
lieferte war er sich schlecht behandelt
hat angeblich im distrikt zusammen
gemacht in dem jackpot selbst überhaupt
nicht auftaucht und dann was er gemacht
hat ist er ist youtube wieder anhalt
gesagt übrigens das ist mein material
und hat das quasi partie einnahmen für
sich beansprucht von diesem song der
song hat jetzt schon darüber nach alter
schwede der song hat jetzt gerade leute
128 millionen aufrufe um es mal ganz
kurz runter zu brechen ein und 28
millionen aufrufe sind circa also in den
vereinigten staaten verdienen noch ein
bisschen mehr ich würde sagen eine
viertelmillion dollar 250.000 dollar
einfach mal geklaut
sobald die welt heute muss die erste
korrektur auf dem hasporter unternommen
werden gerade für mich als sicher ich
werde mein geld ja mit youtube selbst
das finde ich schon und dem strich wird
auch schon dicker also so langsam wird
es ernst
was jetzt passiert das ist ihm star ist
ein amerikanischer nachrichten channel
und der scheinbar nachdem ist eine demo
heraus kam ein das ist ja wie dave grohl
schlecht ist und hat wahrscheinlich auf
irgend aus daraus gezeigt wie sache ist
aber dass in den vereinigten staaten ist
noch mal viel viel einfacher ist
material von anderen leuten zu verwenden
das nennt man fair use mörder oder teams
da hat es ja auch selbst gesagt hat
sogar sein anwalt gefragt ob er das
machen darf kann sie das video verwendet
oder als video jack bauer machen er
durfte ist scheinbar jame pollock
trotzdem unternehmen lassen
dementsprechend gut ich mag teams
eigentlich auch nicht zu sehr deswegen
gib mir nur ein bisschen also das ist
jetzt seine ex freundin das ist jetzt
der lister meile die mit ihm zusammen
waren anführungsstrichen die sache ist
halt dass er sie betrogen hat so wie sie
das sagt und wie er das gemacht hat ist
auch schon mal richtig also transaktion
ok auf jeden fall wird jetzt bei unseren
informationen das kommt sogar in diesem
nach diesem video hast du dir wie du gar
nicht drin vor aber die sache war die er
war mittlerweile irgendwie so sohaib
zusammen und dann hat er aber quasi wer
in einem bett geschlafen hat immer
andere mädels da die eingeladen hat und
hat dann werden die anderen mädels weil
sie damals zumindest anwalt gesagt so
jetzt lasst uns unsere ruhe sagt den
halo dann gehe und dann hat er quasi die
mädels sexualisiert verstehen dass dich
nein wer der quasi alyssa weile weg
geschickt halten danach wieder mit ihren
spielern mit der zusammen
ok als nächster punkt dass er angeblich
homophob ist also schwulenfeindlich
unten rassist ok graz hier schreibt der
main neckar vergeht vergeht als
beleidigung ok kassiert der ok street
corp also ja sagte ok [ __ ] also
fertig das wort übersetzen und das ist
heute selbst anwenden welt schöner tweet
und der quasi schwarzen und wie hoch
oder penis montur zu ihm ich glaube
allein deswegen wird man wie jetzt
gerade runter genommen
dazu muss man aber auch sagen ich mir
auch selbst youtuber und ich weiß auch
wie das ist wenn man von fünf jahren
irgendwie sachen geschrieben hatten dann
kann das fünf jahre später nochmal
angelastet werden das ist auch schon
nicht so über menschen fern sich wie vor
fünf jahren gedacht habe keine ahnung
war bestimmt nicht gut deswegen finde
ich immer so ein bisschen hippie gerade
weil so ganz jungen leuten so weit
zurück zu gehen dazu sagen hat war das
anders geschrieben auf dem haus level
gibt es gar nichts das bleibt ein
vergleich der nächste punkt ist dass er
quasi ein angeber ist immer mit seinen
zahlen rum braten über pro und das ist
wirklich wahr und logen vollmacht das
genauso dazu wie bei denen so drin wird
sich auch mal diese szene gegebene er
sitzt da mit daniel bregler um einen
meter und sein bruder und er reibt
kommst seinem eigenen
wieder voll laufen da kann man rein so
guck mal hier ich habe mehr aufrufe
gemacht als du da und ich hab mir
abonnenten gemacht hast du da seinem
eigenen bruder
klingt nach einer sache die sonst
eigentlich machen würde mehr romane der
jackpot ist nicht okay okay da gibt es
ja noch mal weiter selbe kategorie
polizei die absolute legende von dieser
plattform mais abonniert die youtuber
aller zeiten und auch ein richtig guter
youtuber nach wie vor hat halt ein
videoprojekt folge machten bei allem von
hayden hat das hat viele anrufe bekommen
und das dann auch wieder so eine sache
in dem video zu sagen die hat nur wegen
mir die meisten aufrufe mit dem video
gemacht der letzten zeit berg
ich würde das auch noch mal kurz an hand
von diesen marken und zwar nehmen wir
wieder den raum zur verantwortung jetzt
geht es um bodenständigkeit das gerät
ihr wo ich bin ist maximale
bodenständigkeit und dahinten des
maximal arroganz dann werden wir von
ungefähr
da auch ok leute das war es jetzt so
weit von meiner seite können wir die
kommentare schreiben ob das video
tatsächlich etwas andere einstellung zu
sechs verändert hat hat die in folge
macht möglich jetzt nicht mehr wenn ich
mir das in der form sagen könnte die ich
auch verstehen beispiel indem er dinge
durch ein zimmer schmeißt wäre das super